[Music]
animated corpses appear in stories all
over the world throughout recorded
history but zombies have a distinct
lineage one that traces back to
equatorial and central africa the first
clue is in the word zombie itself its
exact etymological origins are unknown
but there are several candidates the
mitsugo people of gabon for example use
the word zumbi for corpse the kikongo
word zambi refers variously to the
supreme being an ancestor with
superhuman abilities or another deity
and in certain languages spoken in
angola and the congo
zumbi refers to an object inhabited by a
spirit or someone returned from the dead
there are also similarities in certain
cultural beliefs for example in congo
tradition it's thought that once someone
dies their spirit can be housed in a
physical object which might bring
protection and good luck
similar beliefs about what might happen
to someone's soul after death are held
in various parts of africa
between 1517 and 1804 france and spain
enslaved hundreds of thousands of
african people taking them to the
caribbean island that now contains haiti
and the dominican republic
there the religious beliefs of enslaved
african people mixed with the catholic
traditions of colonial authorities and a
religion known as vodou developed
according to some vodou beliefs a
person's soul can be captured and stored
becoming a bodyless zombie
alternatively if a body isn't properly
attended to soon after death a sorcerer
called a boko can capture a corpse and
turn it into a soulless zombie that will
perform their bidding historically these
zombies were said to be put to work as
laborers who needed neither food nor
rest and would enrich their captors
fortune
in other words zombification seemed to
represent the horrors of enslavement
that many haitian people experienced it
was the worst possible fate a form of
enslavement that not even death could
free you from
the zombie was deprived of an afterlife
and trapped in eternal subjugation
because of this in haitian culture
zombies are commonly seen as victims
deserving of sympathy and care the
zombie underwent a transformation after
the u.s occupation of haiti began in
1915 this time through the lens of
western pop culture
during the occupation u.s citizens
propagated many racist beliefs about
black haitian people
among false accounts of devil worship
and human sacrifice zombie stories
captured the american imagination and in
1932 zombies debuted on the big screen
in a film called white zombie
set in haiti the film's protagonist must
rescue his fiancee from an evil vodou
master who runs a sugar mill using
zombie labor
notably the film's main object of
sympathy isn't the enslaved workforce
but the victimized white woman
over the following decades zombies
appeared in many american films usually
with loose references to haitian culture
though some veered off to involve aliens
and nazis
then came the wildly influential 1968
film knight of the living dead in which
a group of strangers tries to survive an
onslaught of slow-moving flesh-eating
monsters
the film's director remarked that he
never envisioned his living dead as
zombies instead it was the audience who
recognized them as such
but from then on zombies became linked
to an insatiable craving for flesh with
a particular taste for brains added in
1985's the return of the living dead in
these and many subsequent films no
sorcerer controls the zombies they're
the monsters
and in many iterations later fueled by
2002's 28 days later zombification
became a contagious phenomenon
for decades now artists around the world
have used zombies to shine a light on
the social ills and anxieties of their
moment from consumer culture to the
global lack of disaster preparedness but
in effect american pop culture also
initially erased the zombie's origins
cannibalizing its original significance
and transforming the victim into the
monster
something we've seen happen before take
for example the vampire blood-sucking
night stalkers or victims of mysterious
plagues learn more with this video or
discover when cemeteries got spooky with
this one